Es gibt so Dinge,
die gehören einfach zusammen:
Pommes und Mayo
Red Bull und Wodka:
Strache: „Schlürf“
Die SPD und Bremen.
Nahles: „Ich kann das jetzt nicht sagen:
Ich liebe Bremen.“
Nee, das geht nicht.
Aber die CDU und die Jugend, also da
Merkel: „Da kommen jetzt plötzlich Kinder,wer weiß was passiert?“
Jaja, wer weiß was passiert, wenn die wählen,
Könnte ja sein, dass ..
Rezo: „die jungen Leute eure Politik Scheiße
finden.“
Nana, also das ist doch …
Ziemiak: „ne Vermischung von ganz vielen
Pseudofakten“
Genau!
Wobei einen Tag später
bei fünf Millionen Klicks – da hat er…
Ziemiak: „Er hat da nen Punkt getroffen.“
Weshalb die Union in nem 11seitigen PDF,
- wir haben das mal ausgedruckt -
dem Rezo mal erklärt, dass Verkürzung nicht
ok ist.
Weiß keiner besser als die CDU.
Die hat die Laufzeiten der AKWs erstmal verlängert,
Eh sie sie nach Fukushima wieder verkürzt
hat.
Ein Sachverhalt, den die Unions nie verkürzen
würde.
Und Kommunikation über Videos,
Amthor: „…das ist nicht Stil der CDU,
sondern unser Stil ist es,
auch sich miteinander an einen Tisch zu setzen.“
An einen Tisch setzen mit kritischen Jugendlichen
ist seit 68,
Obwohl nee, nee 80er auch nich
Stuttgart 21 nee,
Fridays for future, Uploadfilter,
nee, also das ist eher neu, deshalb ist es
ja so gut,
dass ein ganzer Haufen Youtuber nachgelegt
hat.
Kann die Union gleich zeigen, was sie gelernt
Kramp-Karrenbauer: „Die Frage stellt sich
schon,
mit Blick auf das Thema Meinungsmache,
was sind eigentlich Regeln aus dem analogen
Bereich
und welche Regeln gelten eigentlich
für den digitalen Bereich?“
Regeln für Meinungsäußerung.
Jetzt nicht gleich Zensur schreien,
Das war bestimmt nur unglücklich formuliert
Die CDU findet Wahlkampagnen von Prominenten
im Internet eigentlich dufte.
Und erst die freie Meinungsäußerung.
Gerade bei Parteiveranstaltungen
schätzt Kramp-Karrenbauer dieses Recht ganz
besonders:
Kramp-Karrenbauer: „Es war kein Journalist
vor Ort.
Wir waren Herren über die Bilder.
Wir haben die Nachrichten selbst produziert.“
So jemand hat doch nichts gegen das Grundrecht,
seine Meinung frei zu äußern und zu verbreiten.
Aber, dass das heutzutage tatsächlich jeder
tun kann,
also darauf ….
Kramp-Karrenbauer: „Darauf sind wir nicht
vorbereitet gewesen.“
Jaja..